there was a tick tock just went viral of
a mother who had had an abortion
getting through all of those euphemisms
from all the rosy PR that the abortion
industry puts out there
showing people what abortion really
looks like for the mother does nobody
talk about how hard abortions are on a
woman
it's probably been a month
[Music]
and I hate myself every day
it sucks because in the moment I felt
like I was doing the right thing
but every time
I'm going to bed or I'm just alone I
just think about like what if
because I'm not like I'm not a child
like I'm an adult so this just like hit
me on a different level I all the means
in the world
to do it on my own
but I thought like I did it so that it
would benefit not just
me but also everyone else
I didn't even get the chance to like be
at home or anything like I just went to
work
and I just want this to be over with
already like I'm emotionally drained I
can't do this anymore
your heart breaks for that woman because
even though she did a very evil thing
she doesn't seem to have quite
understood it she had bought into so
much of the pr of abortion so which is
which is everywhere
the pr which says oh this is no big deal
it's like getting your appendix removed
oh it's not nice that you're in and out
it's just a clump of cells it's totally
it's not a baby it's meaningless just go
back to work the next day let's go
worker B
you we can't be having you taking any
time off to have a child or raise that
child no you got to make more widgets at
the factory that's your freedom that's
the fruit of feminism that's right you
get the privilege of killing your
children being pressured to do that by
the culture and then getting right back
to work so you can earn a paycheck isn't
that aren't you so happy with your
freedom and and she's now experienced
this and she says oh my god what have I
done
I've done something evil
and I'm not even allowed to I've killed
my child and I'm not even allowed to
mourn it
I'm not even allowed to admit that I
killed my child
and I'm not allowed to mourn it because
if if I am granted even a few days of
mourning
then I would have to admit the reality
of what abortion is
and even if I personally am willing to
do that the society will not allow me to
do that
this poor mother your your heart breaks
for this mother who's telling you the
reality of abortion she says I've just I
thought it was fine when I did it but
then I I went to bed and I can't get it
out of my head right the thing that's
nagging at you is your conscience
which your conscience can be dulled
through through the Indulgence of Vice
but it's still there you still have a
natural ability to discern between right
and wrong
still there and so you you still know
what's happening and the way abortion is
sold is okay here you go this is the
solution to your problem you got a
problem here's the solution almost as if
you're not going to have a life
afterward so you go you do it I'm not
denying that if you have an unplanned
pregnancy that raises all sorts of
anxiety that's what the abortion
industry preys on is women's Stress and
Anxiety and fear for the future in fact
that maybe the man won't stick around
but she says but I could have taken care
of the baby and I went and I and I
had a permanent solution to a temporary
problem and now I just think oh it's
over
and in place of relief I just feel this
sadness because now I'm never gonna
because I killed my kid
and nobody would even tell me what I was
doing and now that I did it I nobody
prepared me for the sadness of the
reality of what I was doing that's what
abortion really looks like
beneath all the rosy euphemisms Women's
Health Care choice
freedom
that's the reality
it's music Monday baby
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it become a member
right now if you're not already a member
the ellywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]